hey I'm Haku I'm the supporter team in
me a lot of my friends got into dota but
eventually they like when they came out
they quit
like they morris check people quitting
so I wouldn't played that for a bit I
wasn't actually good initially I thought
I was like weird cuz I just did dota
like we're just like a lot like denying
the only one I could do it in ich was
gangplank so like I always thought like
I forgot gangplank just won the game cuz
like it's a whole way of just not
getting like XP but like I got used to
that game and like I thought it was fun
it's just like more like no easy I guess
he was just in the bot lane looks like
that pressure is lost now but they're
under rush this looks like it could be
first whoa he's gonna go over to aqua so
steal a little gold out on that one I
didn't always play safaris play mid lane
and then I switch to support season
three issues just cause like I took
million champions and played them
support actually it's like a lot of my
champions now I used to play mid lane
and I just took that down to the bottom
Lane but I just like wanted to roll like
I felt I could do along the map and
support you could throw him a lot so
that was why my family didn't like
really support it like they like they
like didn't know like what it was like I
was like like playing bidding expression
you couldn't do but like all my friends
like they supported me just cuz they all
played it and they were just like super
excited to like see me on stage watching
it I thought like this the stadium was
like a lot bigger but like when I'm
there it's like actually I'm not kind of
small in comparison
it was mostly just like random
challenger team's mind I'm really like
well-known besides like the last one was
frostbite which was a team boy boy made
but we lost to TLA like in the final
stretch and then I just joined renegades
like the week after to feel great
Micronesians really is really good
experience for me like when I initially
got the offer to play for them it was
really fast I like flew out like two
days after I got like the offer and
basically just got thrown into LCS that
same weekend I was pretty nervous like
the first two weeks or so but afterwards
I got more used to it and just like
wanted to keep trying my best but the
constant hard work has shown up here for
renegades winning a lot of games in the
back half of the split but I feel like
as an experience like it was like good
to get the practice right there it's
just like as a team we didn't really
like have an identity at that point it's
like it was hard to mesh with like fries
and everybody else and like we didn't
really get it going till the end of the
split and that's like after the split
the team broke up which was unfortunate
but overall the expanse was good
I I fired I feel like good things left
anatomy is from like the past I used to
watch they're like kind of fake games
and I know they're known for COD but I'm
not into that
I think the roster now is really good we
all work together very well and like a
lot and I as a duo
we like always win Lane and everybody
else were just like trying to work
together communication and once we get
that down we'll probably be like super
high up team
I didn't collapse of duty as well as an
enemy and I mean again just like props
to them proxxon got ninja to show up but
he got a photo show up as well and it's
a multilingual team who is coordinating
better the cloud9 the communication for
our team is split kind of Ben and I talk
a lot and then Sarah will translate for
proxxon and ninja if they want to set up
like a whole play like teepees or
anything and then procs and I have some
keywords we just used and like a lot of
things um I go as a pro players to get
worlds like everybody else I just want
to be able to show up and perform on
every match and I think showing that
that in like a world setting around
against like every for a team would be
good